Welcome to our farm Vibes Life
channel today we'll dive into the world
of modern
agriculture focusing on revolutionary
techniques that maximize efficiency and
productivity in Greenhouse farming
join us as we explore the process of
growing and harvesting egg plant using
advanced technology
[Music]
this method maximizes space while
ensuring plants are efficiently
nourished from seedling to
harvest Greenhouse farming has emerged
as a revolutionary method reshaping
traditional agriculture
[Music]
the technique we explore today
emphasizes vertical growth making the
most of every inch of available
space this method allows us to save
maximum space and use as little land as
possible not only conserving resources
but also reducing the environmental
footprint of agricultural activities
let's take a closer look at this amazing
process that takes place inside a modern
Greenhouse we start by checking the size
of the
greenhouse the Netherlands a country
famous for its innovative Greenhouse
farming methods is a prime example of
the modern efficiency of this
agricultural method the facility is
spacious
thoughtfully designed and and equipped
with state-of-the-art
technology every element of the
greenhouse from the configuration to the
automated crop monitoring system is
meticulously crafted for optimal
efficiency for example the pesticide
spraying process operates fully
automatically ensuring that each plant
receives the amount of pesticide needed
while eliminating resource waste this
level of automation significantly
reduces the need for manual labor
allowing Farmers to focus on more
strategic elements of crop management
the Journey Begins With
seedlings which are carefully cared for
in a controlled environment before being
transferred to the main Greenhouse here
the wonders of contemporary agriculture
are on display in remarkable ways
this process uses little or no soil
instead plants grow through an advanced
hydroponic system that delivers a
nutrient-rich solution directly to the
plant roots through plastic tubes this
method ensures that plants get all the
nutrients they need for optimal growth
without the limitations and potential
diseases common in traditional soil
farming methods as the eggplants grow
they are supported by a network of
hanging wires with the top of each plant
being fixed to these wires providing the
necessary support as they grow taller
and heavier this support system is
essential as it prevents the trees from
falling over under their own weight and
ensures they can reach their full
potential each tree typically requires
two fixed wires to support the structure
and health of the
tree this systematic method of plant
care contributes significantly to the
success of greenhouse farming in
producing highquality products care is
taken correctly until the plant begins
to bloom
[Music]
this is a critical stage in the plant's
growth cycle and every effort is made to
ensure the plant remains in the best
possible condition regular assessments
are made to assess plant Vigor and
confirm that the eggplant plants are
growing as
expected this meticulous attention to
detail sets Greenhouse farming
apart from traditional methods allowing
for greater control over the growing
environment and consistently producing
high quality
produce when it comes time to harvest
the process is carried out precisely and
efficiently mirroring every other stage
in the greenhouse
workers equipped with the latest
technology will stand on automated
platforms that Glide along rows of
plants allowing them to carefully pick
each eggplant this task requires close
supervision as only eggplants that meet
the most stringent quality standards are
selected workers have to be very
selective ensuring that only the best
eggplants are moved to the next stage
after the baskets are
filled workers transfer them to the
processing area where the eggplants are
meticulously arranged on conveyor belts
for
grading this sorting process is
important to ensure that only the best
quality eggplants are packed and shipped
to
Distributors products that do not meet
strict standards will not be discarded
instead they will be set aside for
processing into a variety of different
products some of the eggplants are taken
to processing
facilities where they undergo
transformation into a variety of
appealing products one notable creation
is capatina dine a classic Italian dish
made with
eggplant at this facility eggplants are
cut into bite-sized pieces and marinated
with a variety of spices before being
mixed with other ingredients this
mixture is then stir fried and mixed
with various sources to form
[Music]
capona Farm Vibes life introducing a
dish loved by many for its rich flavors
and varied
textures but the eggplant Story Goes far
beyond
that this adaptable vegetable shines in
countless other recipes each
highlighting its own distinct flavor and
feel from classic dishes to contemporary
culinary masterpieces eggplant remains a
favorite ingredient in kitchens around
the world where the roast Ed grilled or
made into a Savory
dip the cooking possibilities with this
versatile vegetable are truly endless
[Music]
as we conclude our exploration of modern
Greenhouse farming methods it becomes
clear that this method represents the
future of
Agriculture the ability to grow
eggplants in a single Greenhouse
represents a significant advancement in
Innovation and technology in the
agricultural sector optimizing space
conserving resources and ensuring plants
receive Optimal
Care Greenhouse farming is setting new
standards for efficiency and
sustainability we trust you will find
exploring this fascinating journey of
growing eggplants in a modern Greenhouse
both rewarding and enjoyable if you
enjoy this video please consider rating
and subscribing to our channel for more
insights into cuttingedge agricultural
practices and
Innovations as always we welcome your
thoughts and questions in the comments
section below we look forward to hearing
from
you thanks for watching and we look
forward to seeing you in the next video
[Music]